Let's imagine together
we've gone on an eight-month journey
and arrived to the planet Mars.
Yes, Mars.
Somehow we'll have to figure out
how to build protective
and durable structures
to shield us against solar radiation,
galactic cosmic rays
and extreme temperatures swings.
On a Mars mission, there's only so much
that we can bring with us from Earth.
And it's prohibitively expensive
to launch tons and tons
of construction materials into space.
So to realize a pioneering habitat
that progressively grows,
adapts and expands
into a permanent outpost,
we have to think differently
about how we build.
These habitats
and the robots that build them
will enable humanity to thrive off-world.
I am a space architect.
I design and conceive habitats supporting
human exploration in deep space,
like on the surface of Mars.
Not only do I design spaces
for optimal crew health and performance,
but I also investigate
what these habitats are
and how they're going to be built.
Now, Mars is so far from us
that communications delays
can take up to 22 minutes
one way to or from Earth.
And what that means is that
we can't rely on real-time telerobotics
controlled by people on Earth
to supervise what happens
in construction on Mars
or for that matter,
to supervise anything that happens
when we're exploring the planet.
But if we leverage autonomous robotics,
we'll send 3D printers
and other construction robots
to build protective habitats and shelters
before the crew even arrives.
So how exactly would 3D printers
build a habitat on Mars?
Well, first we have to figure out
what these structures are made out of.
Just like early civilizations,
will use in situ regolith,
commonly known as dirt,
and other resources that are local
and indigenous to the planet,
including water,
and possibly combine them
with additives and binders
that we bring from Earth
to engineer high-performance
construction materials.
Our goal when we're designing
these habitats
is to introduce an airtight structure
that can withstand
internal pressurization,
which is what will allow people to live
in a breathable and temperate
environment on the inside.
The robots that we deploy on Mars
will need to perceive and interpret
the complexity of a construction site
in order to sequence and choreograph
different types of tasks.
These tasks will include prospecting Mars
and surveying for a site to build,
collecting raw materials,
processing those materials
and maneuvering them around.
Some of these bots
might resemble the character Wall-E,
except, you know, not so cute.
Once the site has been excavated
and foundations are printed,
these structures are manufactured
layer by layer by layer.
And as construction progresses,
prebuilt and preintegrated hardware
like airlocks or life support equipment
brought from Earth
are inserted into the print
until finally they're sealed
at various connection points.
To do more than just survive in space,
we need to create environments
that positively contribute to well-being
for months and years into the future.
And as more civilian astronauts
travel to space,
it's important that our environments
are more than the tightly packed
mechanical interiors
of the International Space Station,
which today represents
the state of the art
for long-duration human life in space.
We also want to incorporate
practical architectural elements
such as access to natural light
through windows and greenery.
These were features that were missing
aboard the space station
when it was first commissioned,
but which we know are critical
to positive psychological functioning
and well-being.
For long duration missions in deep space,
it's important that crew members
feel less like they're living in a machine
and more like they're living in a home.
There are other ways of approaching
habitat construction on Mars.
Hard-shell or inflatable structures
may not provide
the radiation protection that we need,
and living underground in lava tubes
doesn't quite support
direct surface exploration on the planet.
And also, why would you travel
for eight months to live underground?
Designing structures in space
is all about mitigating risks
and the habitats that we create
will need to be the most durable
and the most resilient
structures ever conceived.
Future off-world surface habitats
will be self-regulating
and self-maintained structures
to support the crew members
while they're there,
but also to operate autonomously
when they are not.
Before we send anyone to Mars,
we need data to answer
some very key questions
about human health, safety,
and to validate each
of these construction activities.
Fortunately for us,
we have a testbed and a proving ground
much, much closer to Earth.
That's our own Moon.
Today we're working with NASA
to demonstrate
how we'll 3D-print infrastructure
like landing pads, roadways
and eventually habitats
directly on the lunar surface.
The Moon is a critical pit stop
to refuel, resupply
and serve as a general platform
for vehicles traveling to deep space,
and we'll use the technologies
establishing a permanent human presence
on the Moon to travel to, from
and operate on the surface of Mars.
What else are we doing
to advance the viability of 3D printing
for building in space?
Well, for one thing,
we can demonstrate
that 3D-printed structures
can support people
in a mission-like environment
right here on Earth,
and use data from those experiments
to set standards and requirements
for future Mars missions.
This is what we did in designing
and building Mars Dune Alpha,
a 3D-printed analog habitat
at the Johnson Space Center in Houston,
referred to as the Crew Health
and Performance Exploration Analog --
that's a really long name, I know --
this structure will house
four volunteer crew members
simulating a one-year mission to Mars,
including a 20-minute
communications delay.
The first mission
is kicking off later this year,
but you could actually apply
to be a crew member in this habitat
sometime in the future.
Or if you're not so inclined,
you can suggest it to someone else
in the name of research.
(Laughter)
If you're one of the chosen few,
you'll be sharing 1700 square feet
of living and working areas
with three others, and that includes
an aeroponic garden for plant growth,
a communications area, an exercise room,
as well as individual crew cabins
that are very cozy,
just six by 12 feet.
Some of you may be thinking,
"Well, building in space,
this is a topic pretty far removed
from our day-to-day lives.
How might it impact
what we do on Earth today?
In my experience, designing
for an extreme environment
that is the most restrictive
and that presents the most constraints,
and which literally
no human has ever gone before,
is what gives us the best chances
of creatively engineering solutions
to problems here on Earth
that seem completely
beyond our grasp today.
Problems like housing solutions
for the chronically homeless
or hurricane and disaster relief housing.
Or rethinking sustainable practices
within construction overall,
which, according to the UN,
is responsible for up to 30 percent
of carbon emissions worldwide.
The autonomous technologies
that we develop for building in space
redound to us on Earth.
They feed back and pay dividends
to how we reimagine
and reconceive construction
happening today.
The fact of the matter is
that the most habitable planet
is the one we live on right now.
I don't like treating space
like it's a lifeboat for humanity
from an ailing planet Earth.
We can either solve for how to build
smarter and more sustainably today,
or we'll have to think about designing
for survival on an Earth more extreme
and more foreign
than any of us have ever known.
And this to me cannot be
the primary reason or driver
why we explore and venture
into deep space.
It's been over 50 years
since any human has traveled
outside of Earth's orbit.
Things are about to change.
We will develop a permanent Moon base,
and we will build autonomously on Mars.
We are on the cusp
of seeing radical transformation
and how we build on Earth
and how we push past limits
to a new frontier
of human exploration in space.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)